in cana bridge of spirits
you venture through the lands
surrounding a village beset by calamity
whatever happened in the past it has
left some of the land corrupted
and spirits of the people who lived
there stranded with unfinished business
as a spirit guide you're charged with
tracking down those spirits and helping
them
but that also means battling them as
twisted monsters and cleansing them
of the pestilence infecting them
we got a chance to play about an hour of
cana in which we ventured into the wild
surrounding the village in search of one
of the spirits called taino
moment to moment the game feels like a
mix of a variety of action-adventure
staples like the legend of zelda breath
of the wild in its fluid melee
combat and uncharted or tomb raider in
its occasional environmental puzzles and
climbing portions
those inspirations are used well though
with fluid gameplay and fast-paced
combat
that's deceptively simple but can get
deadly in a hurry
as you venture out in search of the
spirits you're looking to help you'll
encounter enemies animated with the
corruption
the ones we saw tended to be creatures
made out of twisted chunks of wood
the bigger they are the tougher they are
and while you can beat them down to
defeat them
your main goal in a lot of fights is to
locate red hearts
corrupting the area and destroy those
with kana's spirit guide powers
in some situations hearts will continue
to spawn enemies so locating them and
getting rid of them
is the only way to get yourself out of a
battle two things set kana apart from
similar games
its cinematic presentation and the rot
the first
is born of developer ember studio's
background in animation
before it started making video games and
you can really feel how much kana
has derived from animated films in both
its cinematics and gameplay
but it's the rot that are really the
star of the show these little folks are
spirits of decay
but not in a frightening horrific way
instead they're more like the keepers of
balance
recycling dead things to renew life and
as kana's trailers have shown
they're exceedingly cute
you can find rot in the environment
hidden under rocks or tucked in corners
the more rot you find to join you the
more powerful they become
kina's staff serves as a weapon and
she's able to use it to release pulses
of energy that can clear the corruption
in the world around her but it also
allows her to guide the rot around the
world
so you'll use them to move objects and
solve puzzles to fix items
and even to fight enemies in combat the
rot want to come to your aid but they're
small
and not particularly strong so you need
to pump them up a bit to get them ready
for a spat
you do that by hitting and defeating
enemies to build up a courage meter
when it's full the rock can perform an
action you can send them out to attack
an enemy
or interact with an object that can help
you like blue flowers scattered around
battlefields
that can restore your health according
to ember studios
rot attacks have different effects
depending on the enemy
for some they might do damage while for
others they're a distraction that can
help you take the pressure off or open
them up for attack
you can also turn the rot into a weapon
you can fully control under the right
circumstances
find a large droplet of water and the
rot can use it to turn themselves
into a sort of spirit amoeba which you
can guide around the battlefield
in this form the rot can wail on enemies
move objects and attack hearts
making them vulnerable for you to
destroy them the rot are a huge part of
the game
leveling up as you find more and more of
them as you defeat enemies and help to
fix the world
you earn karma that allows you to unlock
new abilities and actions
and the rot are a big part of that too
as we were playing we unlocked an
ability called
rot hammer where kana channels the rot
to swirl around her staff and then slams
it into an enemy for a big
powerful hit karma upgrades these
abilities even further
giving you more options to mix the rot
in with your fighting style but even out
of combat the rot are an essential part
of kana's journey
you might find objects blocking your way
and often you'll need to send the rot to
clear the path
throughout the forest surrounding the
village you'll find things like damaged
shrines or knocked over statues
but with the rots help you can repair
those things
fixing them gives you more karma so it's
worth exploring the environment
and leaving the main path so that you
can find new things to interact with
the theme of restoration and repair runs
throughout cana
as we climbed up a mountain searching
for tarou's relics to summon his spirit
we found places where the rot could move
statues to solve puzzles or take on the
amoeba form
to water crops
working together they quickly become
your friendly companions
when you jump and climb ledges the rot
will appear to watch you and cheer you
on
and you can find and buy hats for them
to wear to make them feel a little more
distinct
controlling the rod is surprisingly
intuitive in most cases even
in the midst of combat at times it's
like having a second character to
control
but combat doesn't cease for kana when
you start moving the rot around the
battlefield so you have to divide your
attention to keep yourself safe
kane is a deaf fighter though in
addition to a fast light attack
and a stronger charged up heavy attack
she can also create a shield of energy
around herself
and use that to parry incoming attacks
later you unlock a bow version of your
staff that allows you to snipe at
enemies
and take out their weak points we played
through a couple big fights against
tough mini boss enemies and despite the
game's
often bright presentation and the
cuteness of the rot kana bridge of
spirits didn't pull
any punches enemies are fast and deadly
especially the big ones
and they require you to concentrate on
smartly using your abilities and the rot
as well as timing your dodges and
parries to stay alive
it's not all combat though a lot of cana
is spent exploring its lush
beautiful world and interacting with its
spirits and characters
searching for tono's relics provides you
with insight into what happened to him
through his memories and his relatives
serving up some tragic backstory to the
situation that also fills in the gaps of
what happened to the village itself
and you're also piecing together kana's
personal history along the way
those moments are often told in powerful
cutscenes that draw from the animation
background of the studio
creating cinematics that help make the
whole game feel like you're traveling
through
an animated movie
while kana draws from a lot of
inspirations the way it weaves its ideas
together makes for an enthralling
deep feeling adventure that seems like
it'll satisfy both
players who are interested in its story
and world and those who want a challenge
in combat and
exploration although difficulty options
will allow you to tweak the experience
to your liking
so it won't overwhelm you kana bridge of
spirits
is set to release on playstation 4
playstation 5
and pc through the epic game store in
august
ground yourself feel the energy of the
mountain
[Music]
draw on its power
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you